Now it's time for you to meet our second computer scientist Bob.
Bob is working in biotechnology or bioinformatics
and the problem that Bob is working on is he's doing gene analysis.
He is looking at bunch of different genes such as this one here.
Bob is basically trying to figure out how genes work together.
Which groups of genes get activated, say when a cell develops a disease
or when it's infected as oppose to the healthy cell.
Bob will receive data from a laboratory that will tell him which genes work together
or which get activated under a certain condition and which genes don't.
For example these two genes here will get activated more or less under the same conditions.
Also these two here, but these two here they appear to be
kind of independent in laboratory research.
Of course Bob does not only receive data on two genes but on a number of genes.
And of course there are many more interactions so say group
of genes that tends to work together quite a lot.
And so since Bob is trying to figure out which groups of genes work together,
what he is basically looking for is a collection of genes that are all connected to each other.
I'll just give you one example. This here. These three genes are all connected to each other.
This is kind of the type of group that he is looking for.
What he would not be looking for is for example something like this. These four genes here.
Most of them are connected to each other
but not every single one of them is connected to every other.
This gene here is not connected to that one.
And the reason why he is looking for these clusters of genes is
that when you find a group of genes where each gene displays a very similar behavior
to every other gene, then you have a kind of functional cluster so a large set of genes
that can be assumed to be involved in the same processes and you can then use this
for drug targeting or figuring more out about the disease.
This problem is a bit of a simplification of what you might
encounter in the real biotechnology setting.
For example you'd normally be content with these four genes here that are not all fully connected
but looking for genes where every gene is connected to every other one
is a bit more convenient to work with and actually it doesn't really make much of a difference
from an algorithmic perspective so let's say it's realistic enough.